um who would you okay how about this
right now there's I I my my two favorite
movements going on in new New York are
you and the uh 41 the 41 kids uh I love
those guys man and and shout out to Jen
she's she's killing it um have you guys
worked together or you guys I feel like
it'd be dope if you guys did some [__]
together yo I I love they they they so
lit and they're so positive just F they
on no [__] they just Good Vibes you
know what I mean and like we if we work
that's going to be
amazing yeah if we work if we work we
was in the booth and [__] we we played
some [__] that's good yeah who's uh
who's your like
uh bucket Le bucket list feature that
hasn't happened yet because you've
already worked with Snoop and I mean
You' I mean that that's a big deal oh
that's the realest [__] Snoop Dog the
realest the realest [__] like you don't
even know that [__] put me look he
jumped on my song yo Snoop Dog is the
realest [__] mhm he jumped on my song
he brought me out to you did you go to
did you go to his compound in uh
Englewood look yeah he jumped on my song
No I know he brought me out to the
Yankee stadium for free no
charge and he did it with no hesitation
[__] be funny with that [__] what do
you mean he brought you like to perform
with him at Yankee Stadium yeah he
brought me out to perform I love Snoop
Dog bro dead ass that's my [__] in real
life and he's also the same we don't got
to talk every day just for me to right
[__] with a [__] you know what I mean
like he was just a fan like how did he
even find out I don't I'm a fan but he
just loves my song this is New York
actually what happened was I dm' him yo
listen this the LA this is La all I do
is DM people I just be dming these
[__] the people that I don't think I
would ever even be able to work with
right I be like you know what let me
just try and shot
everybody you would not imagine listen
bro the people you would not imagine I
got songs with is the ones I got songs
with because you dm' them just because I
dm' them I think most artists have like
too much ego to like want to reach out
it's like bro just shoot your shot like
bro I'm talking about the [__] you
watch you be like I would never be able
to get that that's fire so that's how it
happened with Snoop was a DM yep just
sliding in a DM listen artist if you
hungry enough you want to make it your
biggest resource is your DMs I know you
didn't uh you don't smoke weed but um
you didn't smoke with Snoop oh no I
didn't smoke with Snoop yet there's a
few guys like I smoke with Snoop I don't
smoke but for Snoop Dog I roll I feel
like snoop's one of the few guys who
like if they pass you the joint you're
like I mean [__] it it's Snoop I know
his [__] GNA have me Zed up yeah yo they
love that word in New York that z z z z
yo how crazy is New York right now you
could just buy weed anywhere uhhuh you
smoke on the corner you could smoke you
could buy weed there's like a dude with
a fold up table on every corner selling
AIDS it's [__] the Wild Wild West you
won't even go to jail no more for it
it's legal and they got stores like if
you go to the store now in New York you
like they have [__] jars of weed
behind the counter they're selling weed
at the store I don't understand what's
happening you want to know why I don't
smoke weed no more why I so let me tell
you this story mhm don't judge me you
got too high no my dude I was doing weed
popping pills all types of [__] okay
terrible I say that right yo you've said
a lot in your interviews for the record
I've watched a lot of them I used to pop
perks okay I used to pop perks every
like a lot a lot like I used to just pop
perks cuz I was just depressed like I
was just like I need some A coping me
mechanism yeah like I need to get high
like I need something to get me going
like and then one time I popped like
three of them at once and I was walking
and next to you know I just woke up on a
[__] porch oh [__] God you weren't
driving thank God I wasn't driving bro I
could have died bro for sure I woke up
I'm like how the [__] did I get here
were you doing like perk 30s I was
popping and locking and dropping it hey
man Pop Lock and dropping so that's why
you said wa that's why you stop smoking
I don't smoke weed no more either cuzz
when I smoked weed one time it was a
[__] standing right in front of me like
you we talking we vibing just chilling
and [__] like that smoking that weed
getting high feeling good and know he
was like yeah yeah yeah and then you
know I take another puff and then I lift
my head up and turn my head to the [__]
and you know how you standing right here
it was three [__]
but it was one [__] I swear to God it
was three of you and I'm look I'm
talking to the [__] right there how
many hits did you take over there huh
how many hits did you take I was just
smoking you might have been that might
have been angel dust inside of that
joint [__] man I just stopped doing
these drugs completely tripping me out
that's good but now I'm clean good for
you I'm clean no drugs pills are
terrible yeah I don't pop pills no more
and the thing is the pills was making my
stomach hurt yeah and then it's hard to
get off of them and then nowadays you
never know you might [__] around now
people going to think I'm a drug addict
no you're clean I'm clean but not would
you but how they know that I'm going to
be clean well people need to know that
like you know I think there's there's
people who who maybe are trying to get
off of pills as possible look that
fentanyl be hitting [__] these
days so you know you you definitely got
clean at the right time yeah I stopped
all those drugs um for you has there
been a moment um you know know I
obviously you you're pretty transparent
about the loss of your
mom um you know for you talk about
like is there any advice you would give
to anybody who has to grieve and still
has to try to get through life when it
comes to getting through such a a
traumatic unexpected loss you know what
I mean considering the circumstances
people can do their research but is
there any advice or any cuz I mean
that's that's a rough thing to get
through and push yeah like and the fact
of the matter is it's going to be hard
getting through it you never you're
never really going to get through the
loss of your mom like you're never going
to just completely get through it I
never did and I'm still trying to get
it's always going to be there like that
hurt that feeling that emptiness that
loss but you just got to just keep going
and find a way to cope through it and
just like don't let it break you don't
let it make you go crazy don't make it
don't let it make you stop going cuz a
lot of [__] they lose somebody they
love and they lose their self they lose
their mind and you got to just like
really put up that fight to just be like
all I'm not going to lose myself like
that [__] going to hurt me and I'mma
grieve and it ain't going to 100% heal
ever but I got to keep going and some
people got kids some people got things
they want to do in their life like you
got to keep going if it's not for you
let it be for something else you know
what I mean 100% yeah I had a friend of
mine recently who lost his kid
unexpectedly in a car accident and I was
just like dude I don't even know nigas
go crazy if I lost my son I don't even
know what I'd do I would probably I just
feel like I would just disappear so
somewhere I don't know that's why like
that's why I just keep the people I love
feel me and I just be like you know
what's another good thing though like
being voices for other people mhm you
know like other people that's going
through the same thing like being you're
kind of like the voice of the voiceless
a thank you yeah yeah um who who do you
listen to right now not not like your
alltime greats but like who's just like
some music if if we were to open up your
Spotify or apple music like what did you
do your your recap like your personal
recap like who were your top five I
don't even stream music I I listen to
music on YouTube I don't stream music
that's the crazy part yeah a lot of
people are like that like I don't know
why YouTube doesn't do a recap yeah I
don't stream music on on um those things
but I do stream music on YouTube and so
what you listening to I listen to um of
course my playlist is like Drake do cat
cardi
B ice Bice I listen to a lot of Billy
eyh Billy is shout out to her yeah
that's my I love her Billy ish is fire